this isn't the chapter I studied for I'm  gonna be a meth head on the street  you're tricking me to think that it's  this but really really it's that the  last 10 I've done see so there's no  other answer if I spell my name right  does that count  I heard that counts skip it skip it skip  it skip it I'm gonna have the best time  on New Year's Eve and kiss a boy plenty  of rich people dropped out of college  I'm gonna be rich Siri what's the answer  to question party to equals MC squared  times the number of Meryl Streep Oscars  to the power of X divided by the number  of stems she's gotten minus the hours of  sleep that I personally have lost that  equals 93 billion light years which is  approximately the size of the observable  universe so it compares it why he does  any of this matter should I go back to  that question I skipped I get it we're  all just Stardust anyway  all right get down in your sheets  yeah that well